[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the hollywood ripper is sentenced to
death for killing and mutilating two
women
mr gargiulo's life work is quite
literally
to viciously the men and the wisconsin
man who reported his parents as missing
now charged with murdering his father
the grizzly details as his mother
still remains missing there is a lot of
evidence in this case
plus the trial begins for a south
carolina man accused of murdering a
college student
who allegedly got into his vehicle
thinking he was her uber driver
the case that sparked nationwide calls
for reform on rideshare safety
and an arrest made in the shocking
kidnapping attempt of a five-year-old
boy
the boy's mother fighting back plus
another turn in the robert durst trial
as a new york real estate investigator
talks about reopening the case
into the real estate air's missing wife
kathy i didn't want
mr durst to know that the case had been
reopened law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the hollywood ripper the serial killer
that terrorized los angeles in the early
2000s
was sentenced to death the families of
his victims say
this this is a long awaited justice
defendant michael farangelo is
psychopath the hollywood ripper was
sentenced to death for murdering two
women
a jury recommended he be executed in
october 2019
but his formal sentencing was delayed
due to the pandemic mr gargiulo has led
a life of crime and violence and has
left a swath
of death grief and destruction
behind him gardula was caught in 2008
after michelle murphy bravely fought him
off of her as he stabbed her in her bed
a trail of blood from her apartment to
his led police to linking him to the
murders of 32 year old maria bruno and
22 year old ashley ellerin
sometimes you'll just be sitting in a
room and you look at a door you'll just
stare at the door and you go
she can only she could only come through
that door
i'd give anything i i ate for her
i ate to hold her i ate to hear her
voice
actor ashton kutcher testified at trial
he was waiting to pick her up
for a date in 2001 looked through her
door when she did not answer
and saw red stains that he thought was
blood elerin was later found dead in her
home
with 47 stab wounds prosecutors say
gargiulo lived near her
just like he lived next to his next
victim maria bruno
she was found dead in her home in 2005
her body mutilated and her breast
implants cut out of her
bruno was separated from her husband at
the time who was cleared as a possible
suspect
the couple shares two young children
then just two and five years old
i mean ultimately i had to
divulge the information that her mother
their mother
had been killed
they would no longer be present in their
lives garjuil is convicted of two counts
of murder and one count of attempted
murder
but prosecutors say they can link him to
the attacks of 11
different women they believe his first
was 18 year old trisha picacio
in 1993 the sister of his friend in
illinois
when i saw her i realized that she was
completely lifeless
there was absolutely nothing i could do
to help her
every year of my life
i remember it like it was yesterday the
defense says the prosecution's labels
of gargiulo as a serial killer
psychopath and psychotic
prove he has mental health issues in
this country
we don't execute the mentally ill the
judge refused to allow
in a statement from the newly elected
los angeles district attorney who
opposed the death penalty
but there is currently a moratorium in
executions in california
gargiulo is now awaiting trial for
trisha's death the cook county state
attorney's office says
they plan to seek to have him extradited
joining us today is legal analyst dina
dahl and terry austin
dina with all the back and forth with
the new district attorney the moratorium
on the death penalty and upcoming trial
where does that leave gargoulo executed
or not
well for now not executed i mean usually
always
somebody is on death row for quite a bit
of time before they have a scheduled
execution
to allow all the appeals to finish but
in the case here even
once he's exhausted his appeals while
there's a moratorium
he will not be executed and it sounds
like the family is very upset
about this but laws do change
time you know traditions in a way you
could call it this of whether or not
a state wants to execute or not for now
california doesn't want to do that
absolutely we've seen that from a few
california cases like this
terry what was your reaction when you
first heard from the victims families
and how gargoulo devastated their lives
you know it's horrible brian this is a
very devastating case
and to think that there might be 11
possible murders connected to this
one individual countless family members
have been affected
right now we know for a fact because you
heard on the stand there
that there are children who don't have
mothers now husbands with no wives
parents with no daughters and whether or
not
he actually is executed this is
certainly a case
that deserves the death penalty if no
other case does this one does
and that is the hollywood ripper
gargiulo who has been sentenced to death
even though there's a moratorium on the
death penalty in california
thank you both turning now to other top
legal news
actor isaiah stokes has been indicted in
new york for the murder of a man in a
parked car
stokes is known for his role in the tv
shows including law and order
special victims unit broadway empire and
power prosecutors say video surveillance
shows stokes
getting out of a parked car on february
7 then firing 11 gunshots into a car in
queens
killing 37 year old tyrone jones on
friday
a grand jury indicted stokes on
second-degree murder and criminal
possession of a weapon
he faces 25 years to life in prison if
convicted
and a florida man will spend eight
months behind bars for the first felony
sentence in the capital riot
paul hodges was captured on surveillance
video inside the senate chamber on
january 6th
last month he pled guilty to one count
of obstructing official proceeding
he told the judge he is remorseful and
regrets his actions
the fbi is continuing to look for more
suspects and release this video of a man
accused of assaulting an officer
during the insurrection
co-host terry austin is here with more
top news making headlines at the law and
crime network
brian a man accused of trying to kidnap
a five-year-old boy
in new york city has been arrested after
police say
he also tried to attack an officer the
nypd released
this video from thursday showing the
brazen attempt
the young boy is stepping just in front
of his mother
as a man gets out of his red vehicle and
snatches the boy
the man runs with the boy back to his
car
but his mother never gave up ran to the
car
pulling the young boy to safety through
the open passenger side window
24 year old james mcgonnell is charged
with attempted kidnapping
and reckless endangerment police say he
went to a hospital on his own
and attacked an officer while being
fingerprinted his alleged accomplice is
still
wanted
thank god that young boy is still back
with his mother still ahead on law and
crime daily
jury selection in the so-called fake
uber driver case that rocked the entire
nation
calling for rideshare safety reform but
first a father dismembered a mother
vanished
their son reported him as missing while
he's now behind bars next
[Music]
welcome back a wisconsin man is charged
with kidnapping
killing and dismembering his father and
the man's mother is still missing
law and crimes angina levy is here with
in more details
about the disturbing case brian
sheriff's officials in dane county
wisconsin say chandler halderson
reported his parents missing on july 7
but now he is charged with killing his
father bart
and investigators are hopeful that
they'll find his mother alive
sheriff's officials say they found bart
halterson's torso with a gunshot wound
in a wooded area
his wife krista is still missing their
23 year old son chandler faces charges
including first degree intentional
homicide
giving false information and hiding a
corpse
the defendant has taken steps to both
destroy and conceal evidence
including human remains that were
dismembered
during a hearing to set chandler
halderson's bail the prosecutor said he
went to great lengths to conceal the
crime
there is a web of lies that
is quite impressive
if it wasn't frankly so tragic
a criminal complaint says a witness
reported seeing halderson near her
property with his parents car
a few days before bart holderson's body
was found nearby
mr chandler or mr helderson chandler
halderson
uh sits here today with no prior record
a lifelong resident of the state a high
school
graduate involved in
many activities such as boy scouts
church groups evidence of rope and knots
being tied
such that an eagle scout might do
krista holderson remains missing but the
sheriff hopes she'll be found
safe i'm always optimistic and hopeful
for a positive outcome in regards to
this
uh incident and the missing krista
alderson and i will let our
investigation and the evidence tell me
otherwise
a judge set chandler halderson's bail at
one million dollars he'll be back in
court in wisconsin
later this month brian thanks angenet
here to discuss a missing mom and
dismembered dad
is legal analyst dina doll and terry
austin terry let's start with a question
everyone is thinking do you think the
mother is dismembered and
we just haven't found her yet well brian
i like the sheriff want to remain as
positive as possible but based on what
we heard during this first appearance
it doesn't seem as though his mother is
going to be alive
at all if they even are able to find her
remains
it sounds like these are very serious
and violent charges like the state
said this individual tried to destroy
all of the evidence he misled the police
and
he did this purposely with these knots
that he tied
so i think that the chances are the
mother is not going to be found alive
chances are she like her spouse will be
found dismembered so i think there was a
web of lies here
as the state said and i think that it's
going to be
very difficult to actually find her
alive
well as you said i hope as well as the
sheriff said that we find her alive if
not
at least some sort of solace or closure
for the family dina so far we
haven't heard a lot of direct evidence
no one is going to take the stand and
say
i saw him do it so how's the prosecution
going to prove this case
well they're going to prove it using
what we call circumstantial evidence
which is
actually how most trials are proved it's
very rare to have
a direct witness to a crime like this
and so they're going to put forward like
they've
you know the they've saying that they
have all these lies that they know about
and that there's you know a lot of
evidence in a case whether or not this
is them posturing at this point
we'll find out when it goes to trial but
they will be methodical as they always
are
and eliminate other possibilities and
maybe show to a motive as to why he
would do it
um his ability to do it she
mentioned right there about the eagle
scout which i thought was
you know a really good point you know
the defense was trying to use that for
his character and she
instantly used it as his means to commit
the crime that he was able to tie these
kind of knots
this is what we're going to be seeing if
this ends up going to trial
yeah this might be the first trial that
we see a not tying expert from one of
the boy scouts of america
and jeanette what is some of the
evidence investigators say they found at
the halterson's house
well brian the criminal complaint says
that when a deputy went into the home to
investigate this complaint he saw
portions of the floor missing along with
a half wall
in the home that was also missing there
was only an outline of that left
also there were other remains and we
don't know who they belong to
found in sauk county wisconsin and the
sheriff told me
today that there is a photograph placing
chandler holderson in that area where
those remains were found
work is still being done to identify
those remains interesting as that case
still continues and still get more
evidence and more information
thank you all for contributing coming up
on law and crime daily
why has the body of robert durst's first
wife never been found
plus the case that sparked nationwide
outrage over rideshare safety concerns
now the man accused of posing as an uber
driver then murdering a college student
stands trial when opening statements
will begin next
[Music]
welcome back jury selection is now
underway in the south carolina trial
of a man accused of murdering a young
woman after she got into the wrong car
thinking it was her uber driver
twenty-seven-year-old nathaniel roland
is charged with kidnapping and murdering
21 year old
samantha josephson joseph sun was a
student at the university of south
carolina she was last seen on
surveillance video
around 2am in march 2019 getting into
the back seat of a car
she thought was her uber investigators
say the child locks were on
preventing her from opening the doors
from the inside she was found 14 hours
later stabbed 30 times
roland was arrested the same day and
court records show
her blood and cell phone were found in
his car the case sparked a nationwide
movement on rideshare safety
the hashtag what's my name foundation
was made in honor of samantha and her
parents advocated to uber and lyft
to add a feature that allows users to
call 9-1-1 from their apps
roland says he's innocent and claims
someone else had his card that night
as he was passed out at a party opening
statements are scheduled for tuesday
morning
let's bring back legal analyst dina dahl
and co-host terry austin
terry this case sparked a movement of
safe driving especially for women who
take ubers
alone called what's my name what's the
hashtag about and can it influence this
case
well let's hope so brian the hashtag is
to raise awareness so that
everyone not just women everyone is
aware that you must make sure
that your uber and or other driver lyft
driver
is who they say they are and the
foundation was really made in honor
of samantha josephson and we've had a
lot of celebrities like darius ruckus
jason alexander they've made psa's
public service announcements to raise
the awareness and also to raise money
not just
awareness so they're actually holding a
walk-a-thon
in september to raise more money brian
so that everyone becomes aware of this
and that everyone protects themselves
against this kind of thing happening
again
yeah double check the license plates
when you get to the car ask them what's
my name make sure you're safe out there
regardless of who you are dina it's his
car
child locks are on where do you think
the defense will go in arguing
for roland well it sounds like they're
going to be arguing that although it was
his car he wasn't actually
in the car which seems like probably the
only argument they can make
because there's video footage showing
her being in the car and there's
blood in the car it's true that that
video footage we just saw
you really can't see who's in the car so
whether or not
this does become a difficulty for the
prosecution to actually
put him in that location is we'll see
he's claims he's at a party will there
be
witnesses who will testify that yes he
was at the party
will the prosecution be able to poke
holes into that
cooperation that's i think where it's
going to come down to and perhaps
there's other video footage that we just
didn't see in this moment
that may be able to tell who's driving
the car
all right forensics video credibility of
witnesses will make sure to keep you
up to date on this case as law and crime
continues to follow it thank you both
when we come back linking the murder of
robert durst's best friend to the
disappearance of his first wife
the investigators who sought out to
solve the decades-old case
next
welcome back prosecutors in the robert
durst murder trial
are calling the lead investigator in the
reopening of the case of the real estate
area's missing wife in new york
to talk about the murder of his key
witness
joseph basari was working for the new
york state police in 1999
when he says he was contacted by a man
he arrested for public lewdness
who said he had information about the
1982 disappearance and murder
of kathy durst the information turned
out to be a bust
would peak the investigators interest to
reopen the case
kathy's body has still never been found
durst is now on trial for the murder of
his best friend susan berman
in december 2000 prosecutors say berman
threatened durst that she'd go public
with information about kathy's death
i think it was a number of kathy's
friends and her family who brought up
susan's name
when were you planning on speaking to
susan berman
probably at some point going into the
new year um
there wasn't a definitive date set at
that point okay
and
had you ever reached out to susan berman
to let her know you wanted
to speak with her no i did not were you
the lead investigator on the case
i was um were you the one in charge of
determining who was and wasn't going to
be spoken to yes
if someone were going to speak to susan
berman would you know about it
i would hope so california prosecutors
believe durst murdered his wife
bought items from a hardware store and
then disposed of her body in the new
jersey pine barrens an isolated area
made it famous
by the sopranos council will you
stipulate that defendant robert durst
used his chemical
chemical bank visa card to make a
purchase at the caldor store located in
ridgefield connecticut
on february 1st 1982. yes
can you buy tools there yes you buy drop
cloths there yes
buy trash bag yes harps
i'm sorry tarps yes are you familiar
with the area known as the pine barren
yes how long does that drive down
about two and a half hours what is the
pine barrens like that area
pine barrens is this vast area hundreds
of thousands of acres of pine trees
and sand are you familiar
with the areas where two locations where
phone calls were made in this particular
case
i am dina after the prosecution's direct
sparks flew about the relevance of this
witness was it
relevant in any way to you i mean
they argued that it was relevant because
they were trying to show that
durst became aware of a reopened
investigation
they're trying to show the motive for
why he would have killed susan berman
and at the time he even said that susan
berman thought he was being contact
she was contacted by somebody in new
york
regarding the investigation so that's
why the prosecution is arguing
that it is relevant it was what did
robert durst
know at the time that susan
berman was killed about whether or not
there was this reopened investigation
with his former wife interesting i'm
sure when robert durst takes the stand
you have a lot of words to comment about
that
terry this was a new set of eyes on a
reopened case and another officer on
this stand
how much did he add to the actual trial
you know i think when he came in in 1999
people really thought he was going to
have a new set of eyes and make some
real progress on the case because that's
what
usually happens when you have a new
investigator and as he said
he was the lead investigator here but
he's got mixed reviews people said that
he
failed to actually interview most of the
witnesses he
had talked about and they said that he
was a
camera hog and was really in it for the
publicity so
i think that you know he didn't have the
bang for the buck and they eventually
kicked him off the case all right thank
you for that everyone and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you